Ma benvenuti alla nuova edizione del Late Show con Karim Musa.
O mio dio ce l'abbiamo fatta, abbiamo un nuovo
studio... circa. Come potete vedere, lo sfondo è rimasto più o meno sempre lo stesso ma molto più grande a mo' di
finestrone e da questa parte abbiamo una piccola parete per staccare un pochino i colori, con due quadretti attaccati
Sicuramente voi occhi d'aquila avrete notato che questo quadretto qui è Hitler. Non
spaventatevi queste sono due splendide illustrazioni di Jacovitti e finalmente posso anche muovermi con la sedia, questo è proprio il futuro
Beh, allora come state, come va? Avete passato bene questi mesi in mia assenza? Io discretamente bene,  grazie per avermelo chiesto
Certo, ho ricevuto una marea di merda per il penultimo video che ho caricato sul canale
Ma che dobbiamo fare. Ebbene sì, quel video è stato o frainteso
o da parte mia non c'è stata una giusta spiegazione. E per iniziare alla grandissima
questa nuova edizione dello show insieme
Mi piacerebbe ripartire proprio da quel punto dopo che ho cercato di spiegare che lo youtuber al di fuori della piattaforma
al di fuori di internet venga visto come un pagliaccio nullafacente,
molti colleghi, molti youtubers, giustamente, si sono ricordati di avere una scopa in casa e se la sono messa nel culo.
No, nel senso che giustamente si sono un po' stizziti da quelle parole
Perché, nel marasma di centinaia di migliaia di video che compongono Youtube Italia, ovviamente qualche "artista"
effettivamente c'è. Ma parlare bene di qualcuno non fa visual, fare flame fa visual, anche involontario. Ma dette queste stronzate qui,
quello che era il mio obiettivo con quel video, è cercare di
umanizzare noi, cercare di appiattire questa differenza di fama che c'è tra il pubblico e lo youtuber. Come mio solito
esasperandone un pochino il concetto, per amore dell'intrattenimento, non
l'ho fatto certo per far scoppiare la terza guerra mondiale nei commenti. Il messaggio che volevo far trasparire con quel video lì, era proprio
siamo umani anche noi. E una delle paure più materiali dell'essere umano è quella di non
riuscire ad avere abbastanza soldi per vivere. E qui mi ricollego all'argomento e dal fatto che con Youtube questa certezza
non c'è, o almeno non per tutti perché, sfatiamo un mito, non tutti gli youtuber guadagnano
ventimila euro al mese
soprattutto se non fai un video per due mesi vero Karim? Vero? Questo problema, a volte,
dipende  dalla giornata,
si trasforma in un macigno tipo Obelix che ti si arrampica sulla schiena e non va
più via. E per farvi capire meglio questo concetto
vorrei parlarvi di un dvd, il fidanzato ideale. Ma come Yotobi proprio perché non guadagni
ventimila euro al mese ti sei rimesso a fare recensioni di film?
Piccolo pezzettino di stronzo, no. Questo non è un film. Questo, questo è...
questo dvd
questo
questo è una pessima idea. Questo dvd potrebbe tranquillamente vincere il premio come
peggior cosa da fare quando la fama inizia a svanire.
Innanzitutto il protagonista, chi è Beppe Convertini?
Il signor Beppe è un attore italiano che dopo aver fatto svariati ruoli minori
è finito a fare tra il 2000 e il 2003 la soap opera "Vivere".
Comunque dopo la chiusura di "Vivere" devi ovviamente cercarti qualcos'altro da fare e
aggrappandoti con i pugni e con i denti a quella fama che "Vivere" ti ha dato
devi usarla per sopravvivere, perdonate il gioco di parole. E quindi magari un giorno sei sdraiato sul divano di casa tua e vieni
contattato da una persona che ti dice: "Ma tu sei il signor Beppe quello di Vivere? Lei è bello signor Beppe, è bello
le casalinghe lo adorano, che ne direbbe di fare qualcos'altro insieme, tipo un'idiozia?" Tadan!
Tralasciando che questo dvd è stato prodotto
dalla Eagle Pictures
Ipotizzo che la finanza avesse bussato alle loro porte e che avessero bisogno di soldi in quel 2004. E quel
signore che al telefono ha chiamato il signor Beppe a casa sua quel giorno non è altro che Guido Bagatta.
Ma Guido Bagatta quello di, quello di Real Tv? Quel
Guido Bagatta? Dio mio sì! Quel Guido Bagatta! Prima di farvi vedere in cosa
consiste il fidanzato ideale, vorrei leggervi giusto due righe di sinossi: "Con il fidanzato ideale
tutte potranno avere a disposizione il loro principe azzurro
virtuale ogni volta che vorranno. un'ora di divertimento, il romanticismo per
le ragazze TI tutte le età. E come non comprare un dvd che c'ha pure degli errori grammaticali
nella sinossi? E ora il contenuto del dvd, dunque
come abbiamo detto prima il signor Convertini
dopo aver fatto "Vivere" aveva ancora un sacco di fan, un sacco di
casalinghe si strappavano i capelli alla vista della sua brillante ed immensa bellezza.
Io non posso giudicare la bellezza di un altro uomo perché ho i testicoli,
però sono abbastanza convinto che a livello generale
la bellezza di quest'uomo ci sia, nulla da dire e quindi hanno cercato di di di lucrarci sopra come è giusto che sia.
E quindi mi accingo a inserire il dvd dentro il
lettore dvd del mio portatile e questo è quello che vedo.
"No no no no no amore torna subito a letto,
stamattina ti ho preparato la colazione e voglio che tu te la gusti tutta. È stata una settimana stressante
e oggi deve iniziare al meglio."
Ecco questo sketch che avete appena visto
è il contenuto del dvd. È uno dei molteplici sketch che compongono il tutto uniti uno dietro l'altro
senza una trama e l'unico collegamento
che unisce il tutto è che lui è il fidanzato di una ragazza che non esiste o meglio la ragazza siamo
noi che stiamo guardando lui che ci parla. "Che ne dici se domani mattina andiamo a fare shopping?
Ti dirò di più. Che ne dici se andiamo  a fare shopping
con questa carta di credito? Mhm
E basta, non c'è nient'altro e tra l'altro
il dvd ha mentito perché dietro c'è scritto "un'ora di divertimento e romanticismo per
le ragazze TI tutte le età" ma se noi togliamo il backstage e gli errori dal
dvd e prendiamo solo questa parte centrale che è il fulcro di "Un ragazzo ideale"
dura poco meno di venti minuti. Hanno praticamente preso uno famoso, l'hanno messo in dei set
preassemblati di Mondo Convenienza e gli hanno fatto dire le cose più banali, mi dovete credere,
le cose più blande proprio le le robacce che condividono
le dodicenni su facebook perché non sanno ancora come funziona il mondo. Quelle cose lì.
"Tesoro? Ah sei al telefono?
Ho capito non sono fatti miei
ma figurati non voglio immischiarmi nei segreti tuoi e delle tue amiche." Sono sicurissimo che ci sarà qualche ragazza, qualche donna che apprezzerà
avere la compagnia di un uomo del genere al proprio fianco.
Però per noi uomini, ve lo posso assicurare, vedere e sentire
delle cose del genere per 20 minuti... e niente mi tocca prendere un cacciavite svitarmi coglioni e buttarli nell'umido.
"Nel dubbio facciamo così sdraiati sul letto, rilassati e aspetta che ti porti qualcosa di caldo.
Vedo se abbiamo, anche qualche medicina in casa, anche se la miglior medicina..." Ti prego non dirlo, ti prego non dirlo, non
devi dirlo perché devi dirlo ti prego non dirlo "...sono senz'altro le mie coccole."
Ottimo quindi quale uso quello di destra o quello di sinistra. "Non capisco perché ti ostini a mettere le lenti a contatto mhm
Anche con gli occhiali sei intrigante da morire,
la mia talpa sexy." LA MIA TALPA SEXY mio Dio!
Signor Beppe Convertini mi scriva alla mail di lavoro per dirmi come fa una talpa ad essere sexy.
"Non ti disperare, non hai cancellato tutto il tuo lavoro,
avevo salvato una copia della tua relazione su questo dischetto." Ah forse ho sbagliato a dire la data, forse è del
1992 questo dvd... no, no è del 2004 lo conferma anche Wikipedia e allora perché salvi i file in un dischetto nel
2004? E perché lo chiami dischetto?
Tra l'altro vorrei fare un salutone speciale al montatore che ha montato quel dvd lì per chiedergli:
perché le transizioni a fischio? Perché?
"Vabbè me la registrerò." *fischio dalla bocca*
Inizio però a provare un po' di dispiacere per il signor Convertini che comunque
ha lavorato anche dopo e ha lavorato prima ovviamente a teatro e in televisione per l'amor di Dio. Vi ho parlato di questo dvd, perché?
Perché io non voglio finire a fare una cosa
del genere, non voglio finire a fare "Il fidanzato ideale" o una cosa simile, non voglio finire ad essere usato da altre persone
semplicemente per la mia fama per poter far lavorare
qualcuno. Perché questo dvd è la prova vivente che a volte le cose si fanno
soltanto per poter far lavorare qualcuno. E questo è quanto, questo è il messaggio che avrei voluto far passare
anche l'altra volta, ma ovviamente ho fatto un video completamente diverso e
non è uscito del tutto questo messaggio, E comunque se dovessi arrivare a toccare il fondo
del barile e fossi costretto a fare una cosa come il fidanzato ideale soltanto per lavorare, ma secondo me uscirebbe in modo completamente diverso...
*musica da night club scadente*
Ciao, dopo il grande successo di "Un fidanzato ideale"
ho pensato di fare la mia versione di questo dvd, il fidanzato di m****
Dove potrò dirvi tutte quelle cose che nessuno, nessuno vi ha mai detto
*****
*fischio e risate*
Ma ti ricordi quando ci siamo visti per la prima volta in quella discoteca,
quando io ti dissi tutte quelle splendide cose per farti innamorare di me?
Beh, non è vero niente.
Io ho detto quelle cose soltanto per poter mettere il mio gigantesco ***** in mezzo alle tue gigantesche ***** per ******* dentro.
*fischio e risate*
Sto per andare al lavoro,
perché non ci divertiamo un pochino prima?
E poi vai a prepararmi il pranzo PERCHÈ ANCORA NON MI HAI PREPARATO UN ***** DA PORTARE AL LAVORO!